this is an extended presentation of
complexity measures on the symmetric
group and beyond
for the 12th innovations and theoretical
computer science conference
this is joint work with neda daphne
you've all filmed us
gnome lichts and mark venuals
let's start off with the fact that every
function on the hypercube can be
uniquely written in the fourier basis
where the chi sub s's are the characters
of the hypercube
and recall their definition below
the fourier degree of a function f on
the hypercube is defined as follows
so note that this fourier analytic
definition of degree
coincides with polynomial notion of
degree where here we represent
f as its real multi-linear polynomial
alternatively we can define degree in
terms of
hunters so recall that a junta
is a function on the hypercube in
particular at k
hunter is a function on the hypercube
whose
output depends on no more than k
coordinates of the input
okay so hunters are canonical
so-called low complexity functions
so recall that the space of real valued
functions on the hypercube can be
graded according to their fourier levels
and the fourier levels correspond to
cardinalities of sets and so these
degree k functions are
spanned by the characters
whose sets whose corresponding sets have
cardinality uh no more than k
okay recall that um of course that
boolean functions
can be computed by decision trees
and uh if you're unaware of this fact
then please pause the video and convince
yourself that
the decision tree below in fact computes
the function
f defined below
okay the decision tree complexity of a
function f
is the least possible depth of a
decision tree
that computes that function
there can be more than one decision tree
that computes a function
okay so now let us um
compare and contrast decision tree
complexity with degree
so if i have decision tree complexity k
then it's an easy exercise to show that
my fourier complexity for f
has to be less than or equal to k
the converse is a bit harder
so if i have
a function that has 4 4a degree k then a
result of
nissan and sigeti in 94 tells us that
the decision tree complexity of f
is polynomial in the fourier complexity
now when we have such a relationship
like this we say that these two
complexity measures are polynomially
related okay
so up until recently it wasn't known
whether or not
sensitivity was polynomially related to
various other complexity measures in the
analysis of boolean functions
so let us go ahead and recall what
sensitivity is again
so the local sensitivity
on a input x is just the number of
influential coordinates
and that's defined formally below and
sensitivity of f we are just running
over all
bit strings and uh computing their local
sensitivity and taking the max
okay so there are many other complexity
measures and we won't
see but a small fraction of them in this
talk and
all of the natural ones that um folks
study and
the analysis of boolean functions tend
to be
polynomially related to one another so
long's recent sensitivity results showed
that
sensitivity joined
many of these other complexity measures
in being uh and sharing this polynomial
relation
okay so this work is uh not so much
focus on the hypercube but rather
going beyond it so
recently there's been a lot of effort
towards
moving towards studying other
combinatorial objects
other than the hypercube so um below is
a list it's by no means
comprehensive it's just uh some results
that
over the past couple years that i'm
aware of that
where the algebraic properties of
certain more complicated combinatorial
domains played a
decisive role in a uh in a nice uh
theoretical cs result
so i'll just
leave these here for you to look at
but a natural question is
since theoretical cs since we're
starting to consider other domains that
are
quite dissimilar from the hypercube the
question becomes can we export our
boolean functions toolkit that we've
honed on the hypercube can we uh can we
export that to these other
combinatorial domains and of course if
one were to do this uh you wouldn't want
to do this in some sort of
ad hoc fashion or case by case for each
domain that you wish to consider
so the question becomes is there a
natural and a general framework for
extending complexity measures
on the hypercube to other combinatorial
domains
and here's just a a list of some
combinatorial domains that come to mind
okay so uh one of the one of the main
contributions of this work is
an abstract simplicial complex based
framework that captures many
but but not all of these uh
combinatorial structures
and we'll get into that in the next
slide
okay so the way this framework works is
as follows so first we declare
a universe u of atomic symbols
once we have u we define the domain to
be a collection
x whose members are in subsets of some
universe u and uh where
n is some fixed natural number
okay so um the notion of a query is
useful in this framework as we saw it
was for
decision trees so a subset q of u
which intersects x and as
excuse me which intersects each member
of our domain in exactly one point
is called a query okay and so
with each domain we associate a set
fancy queue of allowed queries
okay so there's a number of other
properties
that one must define in order for uh
various other complexity measures to be
well defined and we won't
go into uh we won't get into these
details but please
please see our um our full version of
the paper on the archive for
um for a full definition of this
abstract framework
so these three um
these three definitions here will
suffice for the remainder of the talk
okay so let's see how how we can model
these various other combinatorial
domains in terms of this
abstract framework so let's start with
the hypercube so we take a bit string
and we're going to represent it as um
we're going to represent each coordinate
as a pair namely
the index and its bit value
so so right so we'll have um
one for each one for each index
and there are n of those so uh
okay let's move to permutations so with
permutations for each
permutation of the symmetry group we're
going to
have a similar sort of data structure
where i have a pair and in the first
coordinate i'm going to have
my symbol i and then in the second
coordinate
i'm going to have where i gets mapped to
by pi
and one can do a similar thing here for
perfect matchings where instead of a
a two tuple we have a two set and m
of i just is the um
partner of i in the matching m
okay and so uh i think you get the idea
here but
this framework allows us to capture many
um
many different combinatorial domains and
uh we'll only consider these three in
this talk but
see the full version of the paper for um
for other domains as well
okay so we're in a position to talk
about our main result in this paper
and so the main result is that in this
in this framework in this abstract
simplicial complex framework
we have uh natural notions
of uh the following complexity measures
so we have good definitions for these
and we're also able to show that they're
all polynomially related
uh like we have for the um
like we have for the hyperkeep and so um
we're able to show this for a number of
domains i won't explicitly
list them all here but the ones that
we'll talk about in this talk mainly
will revolve around the symmetric group
okay so as i've said before we won't
have time in this talk to even
define most of these terms rather we're
going to focus on degree
decision tree complexity and sensitivity
and before we move on i want to say that
it's there was there's much care needed
and coming up with natural and correct
definitions for many of these
complexity measures so although this is
our main result i would say that an eq
an equally important result is actually
coming up with
good definitions for these things
because there's a lot of
different ways you can go about doing
this there's certainly enough
rope to hang yourself so to speak and so
it's you have to be
quite careful that you're doing things
correctly
okay so let's start with degree on
arbitrary domains so
we're going to define a polynomial to be
the following
and so this bracket notation here is
we're just um
this is just an indicator function where
uh we have a predicate
inside the brackets that tells us
whether or not it's a zero or a one
okay so the degree of a sorry the degree
of a polynomial is the size of a largest
s such that its coefficient is uh
not equal to zero so recall that these
s's are subsets of our universe
and we're just looking at the largest
non-zero one
okay and so the degree of a let's say a
boolean function
on our domain it's just the the least
degree of
of a polynomial p such that f x equals p
of x for
all x in our domain so i stress um
that we're saying a polynomial rather
than the polynomial because
for certain domains you can have many
polynomials representing the same
function
and so this so we have to be a bit
careful here in our definition
okay so um what about fourier degree now
so uh we saw that those two notions
coincided for the
hypercube but we have to be
very careful here for other domains so
first let's
let uh rx just be the space of real
valued functions
uh on x now
this space is typically not going to
have an orthonormal basis of characters
like we have for the hypercube and this
is
because these other domains for starters
they aren't groups they aren't abelian
groups
and so it doesn't really we don't we
don't get this orthonormal basis of
characters
but that's not to say that there isn't
any algebra
that we can hang our hat on so to speak
so the way we've defined domains
it's done in such a way that we always
have a permutation representation of a
symmetric group acting on it
so let's consider that permutation
representation
and so now when we consider that
representation we can break the space up
into sn
irreducibles okay so these are
irreducible representations of the
symmetric group
and these are indexed by integer
partitions of n
so we won't have time to
talk about representation theory
whatsoever really in this talk so if
you're unfamiliar with this
with irritable representations
for this talk it suffices to think of
them as being like um
canonical canonical vector spaces that
are invariant under the action of the
symmetric group and
can't be decomposed further
okay so another thing that's um
a nice combinatorial correspondence here
that
we'll make use of is that um integer
partitions can be
identified with fares diagrams which we
can call shapes okay so for instance uh
541 that part integer partition of 10
corresponds to this shape
okay so we're now in a position to talk
about
48 degree and so 40 degree is defined as
follows
so um n minus lambda 1.
so the way to think about this is that
this is simply the number of cells
underneath the first row of
lambda when we think of lambda as a
fares diagram
and so this uh p lambda this is the uh
orthogonal projection onto the lambda
isotypic subspace
and so uh don't let lambda is to
isotopic subspace scary if you haven't
seen representation theory this just
means that we're
rounding up all the copies all the
vector spaces that are isomorphic to
the irreducible representation of sn
that corresponds to lambda so we round
all those up and that's what that means
okay so we're projecting f onto these
isotopic subspaces
and if it's non-zero we're counting the
number of cells
below its first row and we're just
taking the max of that
okay so this might seem to be a peculiar
definition for degree but
it turns out that this is um
most definitely the the right the right
definition
um but there's a
really subtle question here that's very
important so we just gave
two different definitions of degree so i
gave you a definition in terms of
polynomials and i gave you a definition
now in terms of
some sort of spectral uh in spectral
terminology
irreducible representations so are these
are these actually the same
and it turns out that they are in fact
but it's not obvious and this draws upon
some
um some results in algebraic
combinatorics and extremal combinatorics
namely uh erdos coverage theory but uh
afraid we won't have time to get into
that here
okay so let's um let's think back to our
picture
that we had that kind of uh described
the spectral um gave us a spectral
layout of
real valued functions on the hypercube
so we get the same picture now for
arbitrary domains
and only we're just replacing
are we're just replacing our subsets
with uh integer partitions
and so it's um so it's it's
it's very nice in that respect so it's
like the the same picture you have in
mind about
uh spectral complexity uh
you can you can sort of just substitute
and injure partitions and
more or less you're you have the right
idea
okay so let's uh let's now talk about
decision trees
okay so let us revisit how we did this
in the hypercube
so recall that for a hypercube my
universe was just
these tuples where i have an element of
from one to n and a zero or one in the
in the next position
and uh we can define
pitch strings as n subsets of this
universe
u and now my queries remember
my queries have to intersect each of my
members of my domain exactly once
and so my queries here for the hypercube
is as follows
so clearly i cannot be both zero and one
simultaneously and so uh and so right
and
so we can draw a decision tree here and
the internal nodes represent queries
here where we're looking at
particular bits and querying whether or
not they're zero or one
so now let's do the same for
permutations so for permutations it's
instructive to think of them as being
bipartite matchings of a of a complete
graph
and so here for my universe
the ticked symbols represent
elements on the right partition and the
unticked symbols represent elements on
the left partition
okay and so um as we saw before
we can define we can think of
permutations as uh in this regard
so there's x and
now for uh for q for our set of allowed
queries
it's uh it looks a bit it's it's a
little bit hard to parse at first
but if you if you stare at it closely
enough you'll see that
because of the condition that if i have
an element on the left partition
i can only have that single element on
the left partition be matched to
uh exactly one element on the right
partition
you know because this is uh it's a
perfect matching and so um
each one of these queries will intersect
each of my elements in
x exactly once and this is precisely
what we need
for a query to be well defined and so in
this
permutation land
my decision trees look something like
this and so here i've omitted
um a lot of nodes just to make the
picture legible but
my queries are now the form uh what does
like say i get mapped to
or what is the uh the pre image of
k like what maps decay so so
those are the questions that that uh
those are the types of queries that are
happening
um in decision trees for permutations
and so uh so recall that our main result
was that
all these um all these notions decision
tree complexity and fourier complexity
for like say
the symmetric group their polynomial
they're polynomially related
so what this means is that if i have
let's say i i have some
some function f on
some real value function f
over the space of uh real valued
functions on uh
permutations and i know it's four a
degree
well if i if it's 40 degrees non-trivial
then
what this means is that there's a
non-trivial algorithm
that can compute that function
namely through
as a decision tree so
so i get one of the open questions that
we'll talk about later is whether or not
we can find applications for this and
that would be really great but uh
it seems like there there ought to be
but um
yeah anyways let's uh let's move on and
talk about that sensitivity okay so we
gave a
uh in the full version of our paper we
give a
a natural definition for sensitivity but
it's a bit technical
however for permutations we can state it
pretty cleanly as follows so we have
local sensitivity as before
but instead of thinking about exclusive
ore
as our perturbation there we're looking
at
transpositions and so the local
sensitivity is just going to be the
maximum number of disjoint
transpositions
that have this property of course and
the sensitivity we're just going to be
doing the same thing we're looking at
all elements of our domain and we're
taking the maxwell local sensitivity
so there are alternative ways of
defining sensitivity for
the symmetric group namely if you just
get rid of the requirement that they
beat this joint
but if you do this then um
it is natural to consider in the
analysis of boolean functions but it
doesn't
uh you don't get nice polynomial uh at
least to my knowledge you don't get nice
polynomial uh
relations to other complexity measures
so um
yes so there's a reason why we have
defined local sensitivity in
in this way plays nice with all the
other complexity measures
okay so uh
here's a a very natural question so uh
now that we have this definition of
sensitivity i mean that
if we're showing that it's indeed
polynomially
related to these other complexity
measures and we need some sort of
analog of long sensitivity theorem for
um
for permutations and so uh
you know how would you go about doing
this so um i mean the first thing
the first object to look at would be to
stare at the transposition graph
where we have this is the graph where
two
permutations are adjacent if they differ
by a single transposition
and it doesn't take too long to see that
you know if you start this graph long
enough you'll notice that it has
many large hypercubes as induced
subgraphs
and so the fact that this object has
many large rp cubes sitting inside it
just kind of
makes you wonder okay what maybe we can
just reduce this problem
of um deriving a sensitivity theorem for
permutations to
perhaps the hypercube so that's the idea
so we want to reduce to the hypercube
okay so there's a very
there's a very important definition
that's going to
for which the proof of everything uh for
the sensitivity theorem is going to
follow
and it's this notion of a pseudo
character
so um as it's defined here it's uh
it's not all that remarkable uh we we're
just
calling a function a pseudo character if
it's a zero plus or minus one valued
function
but it's the way that we're going to use
these types of functions
is what gives them their namesake so
we're going to take functions like this
in x
so in particular if x is symmetric group
we're going to we're going to take
functions on the symmetry group that are
0 plus or minus 1 and
have them masquerade as uh characters so
to speak
so we're going to see how that works and
by characters i mean characters of the
hypercube here
okay so a pseudo character chi is
d hypercube inducing if the support of x
sorry
the support of chi can be uh partitioned
into subsets
ci at each of size 2d and
each of these accompanied with a
bijection so here's
where this masquerading bit comes in
satisfying the following
okay so the first condition is that if i
have a
in the hypercube the d hypercube and i
look at its neighbors so these are all
at hamming distance one
and i look at uh all of their images
under
fee sub i and i look at the set
difference and i get
two and this and this is for each of my
neighbors
so from from j equal to one to d
and we also want to require that if each
of these uh
set differences are all pairwise
disjoint
and so the what we so in other words we
say that
fisa sabai takes neighbors to disjoint
neighbors
okay so you can pause the video and let
that sink in
the second requirement is that if i take
two elements of my d hypercube
that are neighbors and i take their
image under
fee sub i and then i evaluate
chi at these points then i get
i see that kai behaves like the parody
character
which we're calling a kind d
so this is uh yeah so this is so this is
uh
what we mean by a pseudo character
masquerading as a character
okay so uh this definition's a bit
uh it's a bit involved so here's a
example of this so you can pause the
video and
convince yourself uh of the definition
through this example
um so this is a example of a of a three
hybrid cube inducing pseudo character
when our domain is s6 symmetric group on
six symbols
okay so so why why are we bothering with
these um
with these pseudo characters okay uh the
reason why is because uh we have this
this nice lemma that is reminiscent of
uh huang's theorem so if we have um
a boolean function that has non-trivial
correlation with one of these
uh masquerading pseudo characters
then uh we can bound the sensitivity of
that function
from below and the square root of d that
should remind you of uh huang
sensitivity theorem where
that d comes from the fact that the
degree of the parity character
is d and so uh with
with that uh with with one sensitivity
theorem at hand uh
showing that this limit is uh is
is not too difficult
and uh right so um
we require one more definition so um
we say that x is alpha witnessing
if for each d the space of degree at
most d
functions is spanned by a set x sub d of
of pseudo characters and each degree
d pseudocharacter is d hypercube
inducing
for some d that's larger than alpha
times d
okay
so why do we come up with this
definition well we have a theorem that
from which we can deduce
quang type sensitivity results so um
if uh x is alpha witnessing then forever
every boolean function f
we have that the sensitivity of f is
bounded from uh below
by uh the root of alpha times the degree
of f
right okay so this um
so we have all these uh so we have this
this nice lemma from which we were able
to just
to deduce this nice theorem and the
question is you know
do these things actually exist so like
can we find like
uh alpha witnessing um
can we prove that don't the these
domains that we're interested in
are alpha witnessing
right so uh let's just consider the
symmetric group
so what should these uh x sub d's be
so in other words like is there is there
a natural set of zero plus or minus one
valued
functions on the on r
s n that's that that span the degree uh
d functions or degree no greater than d
functions i should say
so um you know at first you you know you
would be
it seems like finding a needle in a
haystack or something
but if you
if you know some representation theory
of the symmetric group then there's a
really natural family of functions that
pops out
namely it's these uh things that are
called lambda polytabloids
and namely the these polytabloid
functions that satisfy
this condition that the number of cells
below the first row is uh
no greater than d so um
so yeah so so representation theory is
guiding us
to uh these xd's being these
so-called uh lambda these families of
lambda polytabloids
and if you roll up your sleeves you can
show that uh each
of these degree d lambda polytabloids is
in fact d
hypercube inducing for some d greater
than d over two so here alpha is equal
to one half
and hence these x d's are in fact alpha
witnessing and so um
yeah and so the the things that i've
glossed over here are
some of the main technical
representation theoretical results that
our paper draws upon but i should say
that it it's all
very um you know if you've had a i would
say if you had a course in
representation theory i think you would
you wouldn't
know everything you need to know to
prove these types of results
okay and so so we arrive at the
following theorem
and so this is the sensitivity result
for
the symmetric group
and we were able to show this for a few
other domains as well i just
stuck with the symmetric group for this
talk